[Music]
this morning on the dish the potato
our most remote destination to date
60 miles away from the nearest paved
road
on the edge of alaska
the potato is located inside a town
inside a national park it caters to
everyone from young broke backpackers to
high-end tourists seeking elevated food
in the middle of nowhere to find out why
it works we made the potato part of our
recent trip
to america's 49th state
inside on summer nights the potato might
look like any one of your favorite
neighborhood restaurants hungry diners
scooping up food at the can't miss
corner hangouts
but step outside
and you realize this neighborhood is
unlike any other in the world surrounded
by america's largest national park
in america's largest state
the potato is a restaurant in mccarthy
alaska that requires the ultimate
commitment
to travel and adventure i always i just
had a hankering for
finding a nice wild place i grew up in
the city and i still appreciate it but i
wanted to be in the outdoors ian giori
is part of the small team behind the
potato a classically trained chef who
once worked at some of the finest
restaurants in san francisco he runs the
kitchen
rebecca bard runs the front of the house
i was
here for a trip
i had been doing archaeology and i had
heard that they wanted somebody to come
and revamp the
bar so i i came here to work
at the bar and never left and left my
degree
what bard and giori have created here is
nothing short of remarkable
they rely on only one food delivery a
week
are only open four months of the year
and never know what the harsh conditions
that surround them might bring next the
services that people get out here are at
an unexpected level compared to other
parts that they've traveled in the state
yeah so
you don't expect to get this quality i
mean no offense to mccarthy or anybody
else but you don't expect yeah
we hear that all the time so you get a
lot of adventurous tourists out here so
it gives you the ability to go beyond
just doing
burgers when we do something like a miso
salad it's one of our best sellers are
you catering to a fine dining
crowd or are you catering to
the backpacking crowd or is it the same
thing it's very casual we welcome
everyone but you can get elevated
cuisine here and you can get a burrito
here all day and the burrito is what has
always been the staple in the middle you
paid the bills it's what's paid the
bills
not long after we arrived guillory
showed us how the famed potato head
burrito is assembled how did this become
the signature well it was invented by
the original owner of the potato and it
initially was a breakfast burrito with
egg potato chunks in it salsa sour cream
and jalapenos we took it
and we decided it might be a little
better if we put the fries in it and
once we tried that it was game over
and
it's it's what a lot of backpackers come
get first when they come out of the back
country here the process starts with a
generous handful of shredded cheese on
the tortilla
well that moved to the oven to warm up
we moved to the eggs you guys are really
making me do the whole thing here huh
everything wow okay we threw carnitas
and chorizo on the flat top now you
don't want to forget about yours right
no of course never so
gently damn it you're going to tilt the
pan and move the eggs around you're just
trying to get it to re-coat the bottom a
little bit
gentle is not a word usually in my video
you ready for the fun part
flip it
how do you do that yeah well
that's not there you go now turn the
heat off and it'll finish cooking in the
warm pan
that was impressive actually thank you
then it was time for the part that puts
the potato in the potato head burrito
hand cut curly fries why are your fries
so good you know i really don't know
love
while the fries cooked in peanut oil we
did one final check on our proteins
[Music]
before beginning the assembly
the eggs go first the meat is second
so now all our fries oh that smells
amazing our fries are dripping dry
yeah put a little salsa
yeah not too much but not too little
sour cream okay and next
about five to six little pickled
jalapenos
or eight to ten
depending yeah
all that's missing were the curly fries
salted of course
no more salt no more salt
which left us the task of rolling this
mother of all breakfast burritos
into a perfect cylinder
almost i think kind of all right and
then now
fold the bottom because we want to keep
it contained again
no
turn it 90 degrees you're fine it'll all
end up inside like this yep
and then i don't know this
did you tear your i tore it okay we'll
get a new fork give me a new one
the second time mercifully was the charm
simple basic
from the heart
beautiful why be fancy when you can be
delicious cheers cheers
can i eat
oh
did you nail it
you nailed it no i didn't make it
amazing
to accompany the burrito there was an
eclectic mix of other potato menu
selections
the miso salad with shaved brussels
sprouts mixed greens a soft-boiled egg
and crispy fried onions
salmon with citrus aioli roasted beets
confit potatoes kale
and spruce tips on top
bangers and mash with homemade sausage
sauerkraut stone ground mustard and
pickled red onions
mac and cheese with brussels sprouts
and the sputniks supreme
an original potato dish featuring
biscuits and gravy sausage with eggs
cheese and jalapenos
what they call both a gut bomb
and the breakfast of champions
this thing is
dangerous
a monster it's a monster
a monster of goodness yeah
but like that will fill your stomach and
the person sitting next to you yeah and
when they're not even eating i don't
know how people finish them but they do
should i try no
well
i want to take a nap
the potato is one of the most distinct
dishes we've ever experienced
led by a duo that doesn't seem to belong
anywhere else
i know if i had to run a kitchen like
this year round i probably wouldn't be
as happy of a person as i am i get i get
my winners off to do other jobs or relax
or travel
and
i think that we've both cultivated that
lifestyle being in a town where
the industry is seasonal it's tourist
so
that works for us
so i found my new breakfast food which
is the gut bomb
um unbelievable um the gut bomb was
great the burrito was it was a job on
the burrito i thought he did pretty well
he did i thought i failed pretty much no
no you said that you completely not in
the taste which is the key but i have to
know i want to know how you live
nine months out of the year by working
only three months of the year well they
have they have other jobs the rest of
the year they can does that have no
other thing yeah i mean that's what they
do right that's pretty cool though very
cool nice job jeff